دكتور اولا ماذا وراء توجيه الدعوه في هذا
التوقيت لبسك الرئيس الاوكراني للمشاركه
في اعمال القمه العربيه الثانيه 32
قائد لبلد تخوض حرب وبالتالي هو معني
ان يحمل قضيته وان يحمل قضيه بلده وان
يتحرك بها في العالم وان يتحرك بها عند
الدول الفاعله السعوديه كما تعلم هي طرف
يعني عملت على ان تشكل حاله من الحياد في
قضيه في قضيه الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
وذهبت الى خطوات مثل مثلا التوسط لصفقه
اطلاق الاسرى كما تعلم قبل الاشهر كان في
دور سعودي بهذا الموضوع وبعتقد ايضا انه
السعوديه كمان تربطها علاقات بروسيا جيده
وعلاقات والرئيس الاوكراني يتحدث قبل قليل
وقال انه سيبحث موضوع
عمليه سلام بمعنى اذا كان لديه افكار
يحملها في موضوع عمليه سلام وايقاف اطلاق
النار السعوديه ربما ودول الدول العربيه
اخرى ربما تكون هي الطرف الذي سيحمل هذه
الافكار ويتحدث فيها مع الروس وهم لانهم
من طرف المؤهل عمليا كدول مؤثره خاصه
بموضوع الطاقه ومواضيع
لوصول الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي
الى مطار جده للمشاركه في القمه العربيه
والمشاهد ايضا استقبال بدر بن سلطان منطقه
مكه المكرمه للرئيس الاوكراني
اعود
الموضوع لديه افكار للسلام وافكار جديه
وحديث يعني بمضامين بعتقد انه هذا يعطي
للسعوديه تحديدا لانه قال سيلتقي بالامير
محمد بن سلمان سيعطي للسعوديه دور بان
تحمل هذه الافكار وتتحرك بها مع روسيا
وتحرك بها ايضا مع الولايات المتحده لان
تعرف هذه حرب امريكا ايضا ضد روسيا الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه فهذا امر يعني بيعطي
ويتحرك مع الصين كمان لانه الصين طرف فاعل
مع مع الرسل وفي مبادره صينيه لهذا
الموضوع لكن لم تجد التجاوب امريكي بالقصه
فاذا كان هذا هذا المحور بنحكي عن زياره
مهمه وبنحكي عن زياره قد ينبني عليها شيء
والا بتكون زياره هو هو الرئيس الاوكراني
يحمل قضايا ويحاول ان يقدم يعني للعرب
توجهت نظره ان يجد انصاري وسع دائره
انصاره في العالم العربي لهذا الموضوع
اثنين العالم العربي ايضا لا يعني خليني
اقول في هذه الحرب لا يريد ان ياخذ موقف
معادي للسياسه الامريكيه فالزياره ايضا
فيها نوع من المجامله العربيه
للولايات المتحده العرب لا يريد ان يحسبوا
الانحياز لروسيا لا يمكن ان تفهمها بشكل
مختلف بانه في في مظهر من مظاهر الانحياز
لطرف اخر في هذه الحرب الطرف الاوكراني
بالعلاقات الدول العربيه ما عندها موقف
واحد بالقصه يعني انا ما بحكي عن موقف
عربي وواحد لانه في دول
بعيدها وغير مؤثره فيها لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات